when I joined the academy my misses
didn't talk to me for the two days I
fell Libby did I do the right thing here
as soon as I had like you know the
Monday Mastermind everyone doing deals
all my fear uncertainty you start
disappearing so you're a soldier and now
you've become a soldier in the property
Market too if you are in the job and
rely on one income you will die with the
job how much are you making in profit
every month from My Five rent to rent I
was making six grand a month I see all
these strategies this option agreement
vrr HMO deal selling service
accommodation these are the strategy we
put in our toolbox being in the academy
allows me which toolkit to take out and
apply to it
nabrindra welcome to winners on a
Wednesday over the last six or eight
months you've managed to build up a
property portfolio and you are now
financially independent so
congratulations thank you Samuel thank
you very much yeah thank you uh for
allowing me to come to your house and
share my stories because of your
training mentorship I'm here today and
hopefully you know I can share some of
my stories and Inspire others especially
to the newcomers yeah 100 and you do on
on The Mastermind course you just drop
nuggets and um people have learned so
much from your story so it's an honor to
have you with us why don't you start by
just telling us your back story where
you're from and how this all started
yeah so you know I came came to this
country uh in 2008 as a gorkha soldier
so it was tough but it was tough because
uh you know we had to go through the
vigorous selection process so 20 000
that time 20 000 young people try to
join the British Army and everyone's
dream they trained for years to be there
and you'll get one opportunity every
year and then from out of 20 000 only
260 will come to the you know the UK as
a gold cash holder that's why I know
when I say why gold castles are our best
in UK because these soldiers are not
normal man they are come here by being
get selected and that's why I know the I
came here so I had a Firepower you know
the from that moment yes and that's how
we came to UK Samuel so your soldier yes
and now you've become a soldier in the
property Market too yes of course
because we have a really really good
discipline if you are a real soldier in
the Army they'll teach you the values
and it's standards and if you follow
that and you apply that into your you
know the property business
and then if you get the right skills and
mindset from like you know the good
Mentor like yourself it makes you know
their life easier how did you get the
time to go into property when you were a
full-time Soldier it was really like you
know I was so busy until 2020.
so the 2020 we had covet so before that
I was so focused on my job only do you
know anything about property in 2021
lockdown happened then that's the time
we had time to sit down at home and then
you know the read what some of this
stuff and I came across here you know
the YouTube channel and that I was
watching watching and and I just I just
found wow
this probably you know this is they know
the next next thing I need to do yeah
and that's how I knew that I found you
so what was it about property that
attracted you why did you want to get
into property you always talk about
property gives you a choice it's a
vehicle to get from A to B so I saw I
saw my grandfather he solved in British
Army and then he had one house and
always you know they had one house and
after he retired retirement after 24
years then after two three months he has
to go security job again and I thought
why he did 24 years and why he has to go
to another job again and then the reason
was and I found the reason was
he couldn't you know
he couldn't survive
with the pension he had that time
to cover the living expenses because he
still got mortgage he still got you know
he wanted to go like two or three times
holiday a year if you if you just have
one income
how can you how can you you know the uh
survive with one kid income so he has no
option but to go to
go and find another job that's why when
you always mention about if you are in
the job and rely on one income then
either you will die with the job and I
think it's true yeah but I want to
create multiple stream of income so that
I can have choice if I want to love my
job I can do part-time or flexible hours
but if I don't want to do it then I can
quit and and still I will be living
happily yes so you're still a soldier
still I'm solder and you love it I love
my job but now you're in a position
whereby you've got a retirement plan
you've got good cash flow how much are
you making on your property business in
profit every month so from my five rent
to rent especially last year in the
summer time occupancy rate was really
really good so I was making six grand a
month
but in the winter now even if it you
know the occupancy rate is low I still
making between
3500 to 4K a month that's incredible
that's a full-time salary absolutely and
also your your wife your partner yes
your wife yes she's now quick job
yes so uh can I tell you uh
what happened basically I I know that
I'm working full-time in my job and then
in the Army it's like once you are in
the Army it's like 24 hours so if they
call you anytime you have to be ready to
deploy any times so in that time
what happened was my Mrs was working in
care home as well 12 hours shift every
day and at that time when Army told me
you have to deploy very in a short
period of time then you know the her
boss was upset because we have two
growing children and then you know the
now now she has to look after the kids
and then the the employer her employer
saying why didn't you give five five
weeks notice so it brought you know the
kind of you know the discomfort in our
family and then always my mission was
like we have like in the military we got
like 38 days like paid leave every time
we got like someone leave okay dear
husband you look after the kids okay I
go to care home so that we can make
extra money and I was asking to her why
you know they want to have someone leave
you say you want to go to work why we
have to live this kind of Life yeah
let's find you know there's something
something there is there must be
something that you know that we can do
and then we can you know they create our
you know the good life good time family
time Freedom time that's that's the
driving force for us how does she feel
to be able to quit work now
see she's loving it so
uh in the past again because of our job
and my job we have to you know detect
kids early Breakfast Club always early
in the morning kids didn't like that now
she can you know the spend her time with
them as many as many HC ones that's
unity and then she has time probably she
does one or two hours in the laptop and
he's still you know the making more
money than what she used to earn from
kirom samya it's powerful so where are
your properties then so when we started
the rent to rent the first one was in
our patch area in the Ipswich so that's
the first one yeah and then uh second
one and third one is in Liverpool so
that's one and then other you know the
two other or the two is still in in my
area not close to the Ipswich but you
know within one and a half hour radius
three of them and other three in the uh
Wallace area close to Mercy side yeah so
how did you manage to convince the
landlords or the letting agents to give
you the properties when you had no
experience in property whatsoever I had
anything multiple you know the nodes
absolutely but you will edu teach always
you have to you know they go for big big
you know the uh big big list you mean
what I mean by that is talking to ads
many landlords as possible after you
know the many many rejection
I go one yes
and then after that one it's all about
you know the how you solve your landlord
how you build your reputation
once I got my first one the same
landlord
she said you want another one I got
another properties that's how I got it
even I don't have to go to other you
know the other you know the landlords
she gave me that one and with the two
I use as I know the evidence I use it as
a as a weapon to tell others look
I have these two rendering portfolio and
if you want to see if you if you have
any doubt because there are so many
people out there don't know how to how
the rent to rent business works and then
they they piece the landlord and then
they do in a wrong way and then you know
the landlords think is a spam and then
you know the the head as soon as they
hear company let's well in my case I
said look
I have everything to prove you my
reputation if you want to have a look my
background
I want to pass it minority landlords
current landlords telephone number if
you want reference I'm going to provide
their reference yeah also if you want to
see your property let's say if I get
your property if you want to have a look
how I'm running every three months you
can come and have a look I have every
region to solve you and that's how you
know the once my you know the ones have
a good conversation with landlord they
are keep on giving me Samia wow powerful
again so it's the power of testimonials
getting your foot in the door with the
first one through persistence and then
using that as a leverage to be able to
get more and more it comes with
reputation Integrity you know the
honesty as well if you cannot solve well
to your landlords and then if they think
I'm not giving them good service and
then that can be against your you know
the reputation as well that can you know
the that can bring your business down as
well so so it's not about short-term
gain it's not about get quick Rich kind
of skin it's about always if you want to
sustain long term you have to sob well
in any business with Integrity honesty
and that's how you you grow your
business how much money typically do you
have to put down to get a rent to rent
how much how much cash do you have to
put down my first rent to rent you know
like normally we normally we put down
deposit as well five weeks deposit in
when you like rent out normal house even
I didn't have to put any deposit so the
the property is already in a good
standard Samuel it's just a light refop
so I just spend you know the one
thousand pounds and then that because
that one our first deal myself and my
partner did it in like painting
decorations and things like that once
that done and it's been about two and a
half grand for you know the furnace the
property and that's that's it up and
running and how much does that that
property make that first one that you
got so that one you know like that that
one was our first one as well would be
nervous as well but that property make
like 900 pounds a month and then we we
got it in you know like that one is like
October time the winter coming yeah you
know winter we might have like low
Samuel
and then that money all the you know the
the profit we got got from that property
we keep it and then we use it for the
second second rent for India and how
long are you are you doing this over a
period of time so with these rent to
rents is it is it a five-year contract
or a three-year contract when we did it
we the first one we did for three years
yeah so my second and third one is five
years yeah and then but the the fourth
one even we took it as a like one year
the reason we took it that one year is
like because the landlord he was happy
for a long time that property was
already furnished it's like in a good
condition I don't have to put any money
it's already good to go but he wanted to
see you know if I'm a genuine person or
not yeah so you know you gave me like
hey we did one year but we are happy
with that because we have no more and
you know the not much money to put down
as a deposit nothing it was fully
furnished and you put no deposit down no
no so what did you actually have to put
down for that one so that one is you
just pay monthly rent so it's basically
a no money down yeah no money down so
why not do it over a year and then if he
extends the extends if he doesn't you've
not put any money in and but now looking
like because I have you know they have
sobbed him really really well and he was
really really pleased and he's planning
to give me long-term contract on that
one again yeah down to relationship
again yes how are you know they provide
services to him you did the lease option
boot camp yeah and learned about how to
turn rent to rent into lease options and
you've put that into practice talk to me
about that because that's powerful stuff
so you know yeah in your background so
that's the you know the beauty of being
in the academy family what we have and
what other normal people don't have is
like we have whole package in Academy
let's say I I see all these strategies
list option agreement
brr HMO deal selling service
accommodation these are you know the
these are the strategy we put in our
toolbox being in Academy allows me which
toolkit to take out from that toolbox
and apply to it
a lot of people go out there they see
the YouTube videos about Lee subson and
then they try to pitch all the landlords
list option oh this is this is the easy
way to make money
but in reality
you need to know in what circumstances
what situation yeah which you know this
strategy to use so this list option
agreement so it's first was minority
rent to rent or an assay so I shopped
this landlord for a year
with the rent to rent very happy you
know the no management fee you know the
minimum cost for her household free so
she was really really pleased because
she wanted to sell the property I saw
first even you know the I didn't have
any conversation I saw in the right move
and I asked her why you know the why
wanted to sell the property why did you
put in the right move and then we had a
good conversation but she struggled to
sell that property Samuel that's the
time I went there okay let's have a sit
down probably I can you know they help
you and we sit down and then I listen to
her and then
with the conversation I realized in the
lead shops and we talk about you know
the negative equity but this property
wasn't in negative equity she wanted
more money and then I wanted to find out
you know if she need cash right now or
not I found out she doesn't need a cash
big chunk of money everyone needs cash
well it's about you know the she needed
urgently now or no I found out she
doesn't need it I say okay what's the
pricing one she said you know the at
least I want 125 or minimum 120.
I'll give you the pricing one but I'll
give you in seven years
as you know I'm already managing your
property so I'm paying you rent already
so on top of that I'll give you extra 2
000 pound deposit and I'll pay you and
my solicitor fee everything as well on
top wow so you've got the option to buy
it for 120 if it goes up in value and
it's worth 207 years time for seven
years is a long time then that 80 grand
you will give her 25 of that and you'll
keep the rest and how much rent are you
paying her every month so it's a 575
Samuel how much are you renting it out
for so that's the you know the running
is
from that one I'm making you know like
in the summer time almost you know the 9
900 sometimes you know a thousand pound
clean profit wow so that is my you know
the initial that's my first rent to rent
asset deals that I rented an essay deals
I turn into a dish option so I still now
running as a business so that's probably
profit is that bringing would you say
about maybe 10 000 a year yes so if
you're making 10 grand a year
seven year contract it's gonna make
about 70 grand
absolutely and then you can use that as
the deposit well it'll be adding a lot
more
to put down and then you've got the
capital appreciation it's genius it's
absolutely that's why thank you thank
you to you thank you to the academy
family and that's you know the if you
don't know if I if I don't know I don't
know but I master those skills yeah you
know the I spend my you know the money
to learn these skills and I have that
skill and mindset in my head and I think
it's just the beginning somewhere what
happens if the landlady changes her mind
and after seven years it's really
expensive it's worth 300 Grand and she
says I've changed my mind I don't want
to sell it that's why it's very
important that you know the you have
you know the both parties have
solicitors in place because if I don't
have a correct contract in place then it
can you know the mess up the deal but we
have correct you know the contract in
place we both parties are happy and
signed and then she's very very happy
this is the power of list of some
agreement so that is why I'm paying her
more money today
giving you you know the that you know
the big amount yeah yeah because now
realistically it's probably only worth
100 Grand even less than 100 Samuel wow
probably you know the outside you know
the because nine to five was the you
know the 95 Grand so you're you're
assuming that over the seven years it
will probably go up a lot what happens
if after seven years it's still only
worth 95 and you don't want to buy it if
I don't want to buy it then I have
option to walk away so you have the
option but not the obligation absolutely
so deal sourcing is that something that
you've done as well yes Samuel yeah so
when I start with yes so I didn't have a
deals in the sourcing business so I work
with cordial sources who you know who
has already up and running business some
of the deals I couldn't keep myself so
the one I had you know this Surplus
deals I passed it down to coding sources
and how many times have you sold a deal
then how many deals so not many but at
least you know the once sometime twice a
month that's loads yeah wow yeah so
you're selling one to two deals a month
you've got five rent to rent an sa and
you've also we've not mentioned but
you've also bought a couple of
properties yeah brilliant so the first
one I bought it in it myself as a you
know the first time buyer in 2019 that
is just before joining the academic but
I didn't know how to leverage you know
from that house so I refinance you know
the uh refinance the house and you know
they take the equity out and then use
that money to purchase my you know the
second uh second a second property and
then and then some of the profit from my
rental deals so you really have got a
full toolbox of lease options rent to
rent service accommodation buy to let
deal sourcing it's incredible That's The
Power of being academic because we've
got all the knowledge all the strategy
and we can use
we need whichever we need it what does
your family think about what you've
achieved Andrew said when I begin when I
started uh like especially with the
crash course and then joined the academy
I tell you my misses didn't talk to me
for the two days
because that time I didn't have a huge
amount of money in my bank yeah so you
know I put you know the
most of my money in the course and she
thinks have you lost your mind
you know we thought you know we're gonna
use our money to buy a house
and then you almost you know you say
half the money you know that you spend
towards the course and then that you
know the in the first time being
I feel Libby did I do the right thing
here yeah no kind of thing and then but
then you know the as soon as I had like
you know the Monday Mastermind
and then she everyone doing deals as
soon as I put myself
those you know the the you know the kind
of you know the good environment
you know I believed in myself no what I
did was I was
spending every evening and early hours
to learn those I want to master those
first I want to see first because when I
know all these things and I'll decide
whether it works then the more I started
watching you know learning then I I you
know the trust in the system yeah and
then all my fear uncertainty all my lack
of confidence you start disappearing
Samuel that's what happened and then
when I get my deals my family shop you
know DC always support me anyway it's
just because we both had you know the
employee mindset to begin with so and
then she said wow I wanna know that I
want to help you I think you're right
she said and then she was she is now my
business partner Samuel she loves every
moment yeah well thank you so much for
sharing your story and thank you for the
asset that you've been to the academy
and I'm really pleased with your success
thank you Samuel thank you very much and
then thank you very much for the for you
you know the for the Academy family and
then all the mentors because
you know the I wouldn't be here today
without your help
thank you brother thank you Samuel
[Music]